[Music]  SuperMario Odyssey was announced during  the Nintendo switch presentation and  creator Shigeru Miyamoto says that it  will be more on the core side like the  Italian plumbers adventures on the  Nintendo 64 and GameCube I'm Matt and  this is your hardcore GameSpot news  update the switches first Italian  plumber starring inventor will return to  the 3d Mario franchises roots Odyssey is  set in a sandbox world not unlike Super  Mario 64 and Super Mario Sunshine and it  includes a location that looks similar  to New York City Miyamoto says it's  something that people who like action  games can really get into Miyamoto made  it clear that games like Super Mario  maker and Super Mario run were developed  with casual gamers in mind while Odyssey  is being made to appeal to the core  audience will be able to see for  ourselves when it launches holiday 2017  for the switch for more news about  Nintendo's new console and the world of  video games stay tuned to game spot